curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video
so i hate to start the week with
something so
depressing and so negative and so
horrifying but
we really need to recontextualize
the embarrassing humiliating vaccination
situation in which we find ourselves in
the united states
in a situation where increasingly the
right is focused on authoritarian joe
biden because of his so-called vaccine
mandates announced last week now
remember the vaccine mandates announced
last week like for example if you have
over a hundred employees
you need to require a vaccination from
them
or they can just be tested every week so
like there's a pretty simple way not to
have to get vaccinated even in those
cases
but even still they are being called
vaccine mandates and the right is
focused on it's authoritarian it's not
and it's illegal
and it's not and it's unprecedented but
it's not and all of this different stuff
the context in which this is happening
is a context in which the united states
here we go
is quickly becoming
the least vaccinated
wealthy country in the world
the least vaccinated
we had all the vaccines earlier than
anybody we created some of the vaccines
at least partially american companies
manufactured the vaccines we had dibs
we had it all
and yet the united states is quickly
declining in vaccinations per 100 people
per capita
and will soon be the least vaccinated of
the wealthy countries and it is for one
reason
we have
an overwhelming number
of a special breed of ignorant political
extremists whose ignorance has been
channeled could have been channeled into
other things the ignorance has now been
channeled
into thinking they shouldn't get the
vaccine either for political reasons
they don't want to make joe biden look
good by getting vaccinated or they don't
trust the vaccine and they've fallen for
other conspiracy theories about it was
rushed or it changes your dna or it
magnetizes you or it demagnetizes you or
who knows whatever
we are globally a joke we are so
humiliated but the very people
who are making us be humiliated
aren't paying attention to what's going
on globally anyway and if they were they
wouldn't care they would say those [ __ ]
europeans who cares if they think that
we are idiots other countries look at us
and they say guys
send the vaccines to the countries that
want them we have countries where as
soon as we get five br you know enough
vaccine supply for five percent of the
population we vaccinate five percent
and then we get to 50 and 55
and on and on if you have all these
anti-vaxxed morons they are saying
elsewhere
send us the vaccines so let's look at
the numbers
start with
the world's seven richest countries per
capita okay that's luxembourg singapore
ireland qatar switzerland
norway and the united states
as you see
we're putting a graph up for our visual
audience and i will describe it to you
as you see on the left side of the graph
that's the us that that line that was
leading we started in first place
because we had all the vaccines
and we are now tied for last place with
switzerland and switzerland will soon
pass us because they are vaccinating at
a faster rate
now even if you say sir let's look at a
different group of countries this isn't
fair
yes we are very economically rich but
intellectually we are not a very rich
country because of all these morons
let's look at something else well even
if you look instead at countries with
the biggest populations you say let's
look at china
india indonesia pakistan brazil and the
united states the most populous
countries you see a clear trend where
for now we are still second in per
capita vaccination among the biggest
most populated countries but we have the
flattest curve china already passed us
in per capita vaccination brazil is just
about to pass us
india indonesia and pakistan are
vaccinating at far faster rates than the
united states now you could say well
david as they approach our rate of
vaccination
they will slow down and they're not
actually going to pass us wrong we've
already seen that not be the case with
the richest countries and there is no
evidence that's going to be the case
with the largest population countries
think about it
we made the vaccines
we bought the vaccines
we got them earlier we made them
available to anyone who wants one who
wants to
and we are still within could be weeks
could be a couple of months
we are going to fall pathetically behind
in vaccinated percentage of the
population relative to the
developed world the wealthiest countries
whatever term you want to apply
relative to the most populated countries
as well now just to show you just as a
reminder because the people who most
want to end
all
guidelines
are some of the very people who don't
want to get vaccinated just to show you
what vaccines can do you know
everybody's been talking about israel
israel was very fast out of the gate but
the truth is vaccination rates in israel
have slowed down there's like 20
countries that have a higher vaccination
rate than israel uh denmark denmark is
now i believe it's about 75 vaccinated
we're at 53 they vaccinated 50 percent
more people than us remember 50 percent
more please don't get confused on the
math 75 is 50 percent more than 50.
they are wide open
they have essentially ended all
guidelines i saw a picture of a
concert huge packed venue no masks and
cases continue to decline in denmark
other countries are really taking
advantage of vaccines as they become
available it is completely embarrassing
and pathetic what is going on in the
united states and it's not everyone it's
the coveted anti-vaxxers who are mostly
republicans that's that's the reality of
it right now
look at some of these u.s states
where we still see
under 40 percent vaccination wyoming and
west virginia they're not even at 40
percent
idaho alabama and mississippi they're at
40 on the dot idaho just had to call in
the national guard to help because it's
gotten so bad we covered that story last
week on the bonus show and sadly some of
the very people refusing to take the
vaccine are the ones that say i'm a
patriot
i'm america first think about that
what could be less patriotic
than taking a vaccine
that's i'm sorry what could be less
patriotic than not taking a vaccine
that's free in order to protect your
fellow american citizens and they won't
do it they claim to love their country
and they say america first and yet the
most populated countries are passing us
in vaccination rate the richest
countries are passing us in vaccination
rate it is a living nightmare
partially of our own doing now i'm not
saying we created the virus everybody
relax but once we had the tools
we did not take advantage of them the
way other countries are taking advantage
of them and as a result it is going to
be we are going to be sleeping in this
bed that to some degree the republican
anti-vaxx movement has made for us
and um i want to keep talking we we also
have some new data i want to talk about
that's relevant to this
we have broken down
case growth rates
by political orientation we found oh wow
red counties have a dramatically higher
case rate than blue counties
we've looked at it every way sliced and
diced it there is a new study which is
now looking at
what states have more than the average
number of cases
and what states or which states as some
may prefer have
fewer than the national average of cases
of the 23 states with above average
coveted cases
21
voted for trump
now this is state by state we could do
this county by by county we could do
this in other ways
a business insider article
there's a significant political divide
in how u.s states are dealing with the
pandemic and red states are faring much
worse according to the washington post
report
states that backed trump in the most
recent election have higher rates of
covet cases and deaths than those that
voted biden not surprising but look at
the degree to which this is true
of the 23 states that have a total of
new coveted cases per capita
above the national ratio
washington post says 21 of them voted
for trump in november 21
out of 23 of the above average coveted
states voted trump now interestingly
hawaii and georgia are the only biden
states with more cases per capita than
the average
hawaii is an exception in a sense
because you have people from all over
the country going to hawaii for
vacations and
it's not clear what effect that's having
but at least one of the two exceptions
to the 21 out of 23
seems to have a sort of travel related
situation that is specific
a similar statistic applies when it
comes to the number of deaths of the 18
states with new death tolls higher than
the national ratio
14 of those voted for the former
president donald trump when it comes to
the 17 least vaccinated states 16 all
but georgia
voted for trump
this is math guys now
there is a there's been an attempted
rebuttal at this data
which says
you also need to
equalize
for population
density and i've looked at those
analyses which say that it's much more
even where is it worse is it worse in
red versus blue sort of trying to point
to a different factor
it's not convincing based on everything
i've read
when when you look at a county level
analysis
when you look at a state level analysis
no matter how you slice and dice it it
is abundantly clear that the group that
is most against the vaccine is trump
voting republicans
and the places with more trump voting
republicans
are the places that disproportionately
have more cases and have more deaths now
i know some of you might say david david
david hold on don't
remember it was new york
it was massachusetts it was california
this was an early result
before we knew anything about the virus
about the fact that the places with the
most direct flights to the places that
had early cases asia
and europe
were the hardest hit early but when you
look at the numbers once vaccinations
started once we understood what
guidelines worked once we understood how
things worked
it is overwhelmingly worse in the places
with a lot of republicans who aren't
getting vaccinated it doesn't matter how
you slice and dice the data
are there people
so deluded
that they want to get covered in order
to make biden look worse are there
people who think you know what if i get
it that'll be another case and that'll
make biden look bad is it does anybody
know has anybody come across people
matching that description if so i want
to hear about it but the numbers are
humiliating they're humiliating in terms
of cases they're humiliating in terms of
vaccines now the what's the upshot
it looks like
in the same way as europe is starting to
get over the delta wave
i'm hopeful because remember i i don't
for me this is just about health it's
not about oh who could look good or bad
based on where no
it looks as though numbers are leveling
off and cases are even down about 7 over
the last 10 days or so let's hope it
continues uh the vaccine quote mandates
from joe biden
will take some time to have an effect
but hopefully they will and we will be
tracking it all for you let me know
what's going on in your state you can
find me on twitter deepakman
and send me your thoughts
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival
in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
slash
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
our program does depend on folks like
you who sign up and get a membership on
our website that website is
joinpacman.com we are primarily an
independently funded
program we depend on folks who just go
to our website and get a membership you
get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show you get access to
the daily bonus show and a bunch of
other great perks it's really
inexpensive and i encourage you to sign
up today you can go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
or
you've got to spell this one correctly
this is a code that often misspelled
my hipaa you know how those
right-wingers like to say when you ask
hey are you vaccinated they go that's my
hipaa
that's my hipaa if you spell my hipaa
correctly it gives you an even bigger
discount at joinpacman.com
all right we need your help my help we
need as a as a as a society to come
together to figure out
who
left the pipe bombs in washington dc
um on the eve of the january sixth trump
riots the fbi has now released
significant information and video but
they don't know who the person in the
video is so we're going to go through
the the different information few days
ago fbi in washington dc
saying
the fbi's washington field office has
released new information and video
regarding the suspect who placed pipe
bombs in the capitol hill neighborhood
of dc in january and is seeking tips
from the public identifying the
perpetrator of this attempted attack
remains a priority
okay
the new information includes a virtual
map highlighting the route or route that
the suspect walked while placing the two
bombs on january 5th between 7 30 and 8
30 pm that's the night before the riots
at the capitol one device was in an
alley behind the rnc headquarters on
first street the other was next to a
parch bent park bench near the dnc
headquarters
on uh
south south capitol street
new video footage shows the pipe bomb
suspect sitting on a bench near the dnc
where the suspect later placed the pipe
bomb from this vantage point a full
front view of the suspect can be
observed they don't appear to know who
this is yet
the video which you can review
um is quite detailed
and it starts with actually showing the
locations on a map and the route that
was believed to be taken there are
multiple videos as we're showing our
television audience where you see the
individual in a gray what looks like a
gray hoodie walking by
with a bag in which presumably they have
the pipe bombs this is a recreation of
the route using all sorts of of of
cameras that are there this is a video
that's been much uh promoted where the
individual does not look like a
particularly tall individual
is sort of what i would call is looking
casual as they have this bag presumably
with a pipe bomb and you see them
stop a number of times and look around
put the backpack down
um i believe in this video someone
actually walks by and they sort of play
cool looks like they're maybe on their
phone here they are wearing a mask and
of course that
may be more for making it difficult to
identify them than it is uh
because they want to stop the spread
let's put it that way an individual
walked by with their dog and the suspect
in question just kind of stood around
and then after that person walked by
they kind of go back over to the
backpack
pick it up
and then presumably keep moving they are
believed to have taken kind of a winding
route again maybe trying to
um
throw off surveillance in some sense
uh then sitting down on a park bench
with the very same backpack now there's
a couple things i wanna mention that
have been speculated about and again the
most important thing here before i do
any speculation
is
there is no way in hell
that there are no leads out there
they're they're simply
you know whether it's people that know
the individual and suspect it might be
someone they know
there's probably some of those although
maybe not
um
other people
who observed
suspicious behavior
maybe somebody who can say i think that
someone might have been here buying some
of the stuff you might need for the pipe
bombs the odds that no one knows
anything are very low so if you know
anything
get in touch with the fbi we're now
watching the suspect getting up from
that bench and continuing to walk with
the backpack
a 1-800 call fbi 1-800 call fbi 1-800
call fbi
you can also submit your tips online at
tips.fbi.gov
tips can remain anonymous if you would
like
okay
um
check out the video for yourselves now
now to the speculation and i this is
i i'm sort of doing this to get more
people watching the video and even if
you disagree with any of the
speculations that have floated around
maybe you will notice something about
the video that is useful
there are images where the way the
hoodie looks on the individual's head
who we're now seeing walk around
uh near some trash cans in a back alley
it looks like they may have sort of long
hair that's in either a ponytail or a
bun
that's been stuffed in the hoodie
because the the behind in the neck area
the hoodie looks very bulky so that's
one speculation it may be totally wrong
this may be someone with short hair
this has led to some speculation that
this might be a woman now the fbi has
not said and overwhelmingly people who
do these things are male but i think
just as a general thing
until we really know anything we should
just keep an open mind about everything
now i don't know if i want to say
well where is that coming from i
apologize um
this this again just continues to be
idle speculation a friend of mine and a
bunch of people on twitter are saying
hey look if that that it looks like sort
of a short person maybe hiding a
ponytail could that be marjorie taylor
green and of course there's absolutely
no evidence for that but it is funny
that a friend of mine texted me about it
and then i started searching around and
a bunch of people are actually saying
this could be male could be female could
be young could be old we just we just
don't know
and
my belief is someone must know something
and if that's you
please contact the fbi 1 1-800 call fbi
tips.fbi.gov this could be anybody any
any profile whatsoever is the important
thing
we had the 20th anniversary of 911 over
the weekend
and um there is
so much that can be said and yet how
much is there that is new that can be
said about 911 that we've not said on
prior anniversaries for me one of the
most important things
was the stark contrast
over the 20 years between the 2021
republican party
and the 2001 republican party and how
out of place
then president george w bush looks
within the modern republican party now
whoa whoa whoa
am i rewriting history and
rehabilitating the image of george w
bush no that's not what i'm doing
am i saying george w bush's foreign
policy decisions back in 2001 and two
and three made any sense no
no i'm not doing that
but what i am pointing out is as much of
a disaster as was george w bush on
foreign policy and in so many other ways
the republican party today under the
maga brand has become something orders
of magnitude more insane and so what i'm
going to play for you here is a little
bit of a speech
that george w bush gave
um on saturday on the anniversary of 911
in which he did something that i think
is really accurate actually
he likened
the trump writers of january 6th
to the 911 terrorists
of 9 11 2001 and pointed out it's not
just from abroad
that these threats can come
but even from inside as well
now i i want to again say
in this speech george w bush says a ton
of nonsense i don't like bush i don't
think he was a good president i didn't
vote for but you know all these
different things even in this speech
bush still acts like his military
actions in afghanistan and iraq made
sense
i don't agree with that
but
he correctly draws a line
between the trump rioters and the 911
terrorists and saying it's all
people who wish harm or want to do harm
to the united states let's take a listen
to george w bush on saturday
as a nation our adjustments have been
profound
many americans struggled to understand
why an enemy would hate us with such
zeal
the security measures incorporated into
our lives
are both sources of comfort
and reminders of our vulnerability
but they're this is an example the
security measures are also something
that many of us are concerned are
sacrificing privacy without really
providing security like that's a huge
part of security measures you know so so
there's still a ton of neocon propaganda
here but he eventually gets to something
very important
and we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders right
but from violence that gathers within
right
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but then there's disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
he is
absolutely right
i saw a great comment on reddit which
said
in an attempt to be the most
conservative member of their party
they're becoming so reactionary that
they're starting to reject basic aspects
of human civilization
like empathy for others that can't
directly help you
and that is exactly the type of thing
that george w bush is pointing to now
again because i know
you know the the glenn greenwald types
are very quick to say look at all these
soft leftists
lionizing bush and forget no no no no no
even in this speech bush acts like his
military actions in iraq and afghanistan
made sense
uh after trump though bush comparatively
sounds
relatively empathetic
comparatively wise and we have to still
remember all the bad we're not rehabbing
george w bush
but
um it is a stark contrast here
between what the republican party was in
2001 which was already horrible it was
horrible in 2001 to what it is today
i get the sense that bush as a person
feels much more comfortable and safe
around the obamas
than the trumpists and this is also a
reminder that the obama democratic party
is not the the super left socialist
thing that the right believes it to be
that's an important reminder here as
well now the problem is when you try to
talk about this stuff everybody wants
black and white david do you think bush
is great or do you think he's terrible
well he was horrible on policy
for the times of 2001 to three
he was a disgusting reactionary a
terrible neocon
and he has accurately identified the
lunatic stray of the republican party to
trumpism
and has accurately found an analogy
between the trump rioters and the 911
terrorists that's it you know people
want oh if bush gets along with obama
that means obama is actually a right
winger no obama's a center-left democrat
bush is a is a republican
but compared to maga cultists who at
every opportunity do what is absolutely
worst for the country they are closer to
each other in that way while still being
significantly different politically and
part of the problem is
it's not just the people on the right
who want to say oh obama's a socialist
marxist biden's a socialist marxist
there's also people on the left who want
to say if there's any agreement between
a republican and a democrat it must mean
the democrat is actually a right winger
let's try not to fall for these tired
tropes that are completely
counterproductive in actually discussing
substantively the issues facing the
country
bush was a disaster
and good for bush triggering the maga
people by saying the january 6 people
are more similar to the 9 11 terrorists
than you might think now one other
thought
on twitter and reddit i saw these
right-wing nuts saying
when bush referred to the domestic
people he was talking about antifa and
black lives matter no he wasn't he
obviously wasn't there's no way in hell
that that's what george w bush was
talking about let's take a quick break
we'll have more on this
and the rest of today's stories on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right so as we talked about earlier
we just had the 20th anniversary of 9
11.
we talked a little bit about the george
w bush speech on the 20th anniversary
there were a number of different events
with multiple former presidents
commemorating um the 20-year anniversary
of the 9 11 attacks i've told my story
of where i was on 9 11 many times i was
sitting in my morning psychology class
in high school and a known troublemaker
came back from wandering the halls and
said we're under attack and our teacher
the late great mr donald palmisano told
him
you've caused enough trouble today i'm
sure everything's fine sit down and we
quickly learned not everything was fine
mr palmisano ended up apologizing to
that student when we were ultimately
back in class and said
you were right and i was wrong
um so on saturday the 20th anniversary
of 9 11 presidents biden obama bush and
clinton all attended and spoke at
various events and commemorations
trump didn't go to any of that stuff he
later stopped by ground zero sort of
close by and took some pictures with
firefighters
didn't go to the actual events
but what donald trump did do on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 is boxing commentary
i'm not kidding as i posted to twitter
on saturday tongue-in-cheek of course
a sober commemoration of 911
by a former president this was promoted
for a while
president trump hosts
the most anticipated
heavyweight fight of the year
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
holyfield versus belfort
i was shocked by this also since
holyfield's almost 60 years old i didn't
realize that this was so anticipated but
okay
and it was promoted as having full live
in-person commentary by president trump
apparently it was trump and donald trump
jr
and how many layers are there to this
stuff not only is a former president
doing boxing commentary on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11.
not only is he doing it with his doofus
son but the sun
even sort of turns it into a grift which
you'll hear in this clip take a look at
this we're here at hard rock in
florida
by the way the audio is all you just you
can barely even hear trump to have
hopefully a very
great night with a lot of great
champions
for them they're going to be having a
good time i wouldn't want to do it a lot
of people wouldn't want to do it but
they look like they're going to have a
good time i just saw a couple of the
fighters the desperation from don jr to
be liked by his dad and the stupid
forced laughs at every dumb joke it's
almost sad they love doing this stuff so
we're going to watch evander and detour
we're going to watch anderson silva
[Music]
guys i think this is going to be a lot
of levity at the end of a rather somber
day you have a little bit of a somber
levity at the end of a summer day don't
forget to shoot me your questions i may
have to finally twist his arm a little
bit to find out about area 51 and the
aliens or whatever else you may want to
ask about so you know what this is he he
was doing this grift all day don jr this
was a pay-per-view event
and so don jr was teasing you know
i'm gonna take questions and maybe some
of the questions will be about the truth
about aliens what does trump know about
aliens because he's the president and he
was told all sorts of stuff
the it's all a grift in the end they
will do anything for a buck and or for
publicity we're gonna have some fun at
the end of a somber day and i'm just
looking forward to it some of the great
fight legends are here guys you can
check it out on any cable network or
fight tv tune in now yeah
um it it's just nothing there's nothing
that isn't a grift with these people
um
let's look at some of the actual
commentary just to be thorough and it's
like then they start explaining to trump
sir people are chanting your name and
it's just oh so weird this was the 20th
anniversary of 911 there's a former
president okay if obama had done boxing
commentary on the 20th anniversary of 9
11 it would be 24 7 coverage for three
days on fox news
about how anti-american obama's
here we go that was a fantastic job by a
really great young man
he's got a big future and
we're just honored
thank you
that's what everybody's seen in the
audience i don't think i hear that back
home
everybody's screaming right now
[Applause]
do you think trump's at all embarrassed
that where he's going now for this is
where he's doing boxing commentary like
this is the stage on which he now
appears
thank you very much what an amazing
rendition of the national anthem
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody thank you
this is an honor to be with you and what
a great evening and
i think you're going to see an
incredible fight and
jorge it's great junior it's great to be
with you guys and uh champions we love
you man special people special warriors
[Applause]
i don't feel i feel like i live in a
different country than where this
environment is going on like it's almost
surreal that this is where
this is what one former president was
doing on 9 11.
we're still going strong
[Applause]
that's good
they got the chat going that's been
going around stadiums in the college
football for the last couple of days
there's don jr
is there something sad and pathetic
about don jr having to come in and say
yeah yep this is the same chant that all
the
the people in stadiums have been doing
it's a degree of please love me dad that
actually makes me sad for don jr in a
way
well it's a great honor and thank you
very much thank you everybody very much
we love our country i love our country
thank you very much
so we're going to see a great fight
tonight and uh we've seen some good ones
that last one we're going to call it i
think it's going to be a short one you
think it's going to be well you've been
calling him very accurately i think this
is going to be a short one maybe you're
right because of himself
it's very explosive yes he is it's
always uh holy [ __ ] crap
are they even at the venue like it
almost seems like trump's not even at
the venue it's something about this is
all very weird and and two warriors
very exciting isn't it huh
very exciting
two great fighters one's a boxer though
the others uh
mma
yeah all right so there's trump's
analysis there uh this is just
embarrassing and again the world's
laughing at all of it and uh it's just
what are people thinking what are people
thinking one other little aspect of this
that i did want to touch on which starts
to actually go over the line into the
politically absurd and let's talk about
that next
so okay i already told you
20th anniversary of 911
uh bush clinton biden
obama they went to different events
george w bush gave an interesting speech
that contained some propaganda but also
accurately kind of drew a line
between
the 9 11 terrorists and the trump
rioters of january 6th and we've talked
about that as i already told you trump
did boxing commentary on the 20th
anniversary of 911 but here's something
that's just extra pathetic
in
pre-fight trump participated in
pre-fight stuff as well he called in to
like a weigh-in or something like that
really really presidential
um and he said that he would be able to
knock out joe biden in seconds this is
one former president
saying he'd be able to beat up
another
or the current president and former vice
president joe biden
um
our country is a joke right
am i is my perception wrong here like
we're we're a complete and total joke
look at this
listen to this
amazing this comes from josh peter of
usa today
if you had to box somebody on saturday
night
who would it be
and what would the fight look like yeah
well if i had to pick somebody in the
world not only a professional boxer
because i'll take a pass on the
professional boxes that can be a very
dangerous subject but if you said do i
if i had to box somebody anybody i think
probably my easiest fight would be joe
biden because
i think he'd go down very very quickly
very very quickly you know he once said
oh i'd like to take him behind the bar
and he'd be in big trouble if he ever
did now i think biden would go down
within the first few seconds the first
few seconds
all right president trump thank you so
much for your time we will see you on
saturday night
oh god guys i don't
i mean
what
how
what do we what do we say you know
um when the former president was asked
if if you could box anyone you know who
who would it be and he says well
i think if i boxed joe biden it would be
really easy
and
he would go down
within a few seconds
how pathetic is this stuff how pathetic
is this stuff if if obama had said this
about bush what do you think would have
been the reaction i mean it's it's just
lunacy we are a joke
and by the way i don't know that i even
you know this is sort of like
who would win in a fight an oversized
duck or tiny horses you know those weird
things
i actually think
joe biden would would crush donald trump
i don't know much about fighting boxing
you know we would need to go to other
people
but just based on how biden gets around
and jogs and bikes and different things
and then you know trump had to be helped
down a ramp and it's just
the guy's not in good shape
it seems to me
that
trump is is not a guy who would do
particularly well in a fight i don't
know i mean he's obese and he's he's
anyway who cares not only does trump
appear to be completely out of his mind
with this stuff where the first thing is
if you fought someone who would it be
it'd be biden
he also seems to be living in a fantasy
world when it comes to his own strength
and his own fitness and everything i i
am this this weekend in particular you
know often people write in and they say
david how do you deal with just all this
wacky news all the time isn't it
demoralizing and
and i say you know i'm really
desensitized to most of it
i'm just so used to covering this stuff
the stuff this weekend really pushed it
to a new level where i was actually
sitting there looking at my screen
getting ready for the show saying what
the hell
is going on in this country right now
just a humiliating weekend for the
united states on vaccines on the stuff
trump is doing etc
and that's before i even talk about rudy
giuliani's seemingly drunk rant
at his 9 11 dinner that's what we'll
start with after this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay let's talk about
a few other things that happened this
weekend some of them are 911 related you
know rudy giuliani was the mayor of new
york city when 9 11 happened and there
is certainly
debate about the degree to which rudy
giuliani handled 911 properly
but there is no question that he was
experiencing a very solid and healthy
approval rating at the time he was seen
colloquially as america's mayor and i'm
not saying i agree with him on all
policy but he had a high approval rating
and was relatively well respected that
has gone into the toilet over the years
as he has gotten more and more involved
with donald trump and then really
embarrassed himself regularly with all
of the voter fraud stuff and appearing
on television seemingly drunk multiple
times a charge which he has denied but
he's continued holding this annual 9 11
dinner the 9 11 dinner this past weekend
went completely off the rails with rudy
giuliani showing up apparently so drunk
that he was making no sense and slurring
something he might do not drunk also
we're not making fun of alcoholism we're
merely just again stating the fact that
this is a guy who's been put in
positions of significant power and
responsibility
and he may not be
he may be lacking the capacity for it
partially because of what seems to be a
drinking problem
um many reports about they would try to
keep rudy off of nighttime television
because it was more likely he would be
drunk and so on and so forth and we're
going to look at a couple of clips and
it just just the degree to which this
guy has fallen from grace is insane
business insider reporting video
captures rudy giuliani's rambling speech
at a 9 11 dinner in which he
impersonated queen elizabeth ii
yeah rudy gave a rambling speech at his
annual dinner the former mayor
impersonated queen elizabeth said he's
never socialized with disgraced prince
andrew giuliani also described how he
wanted to grab general mark milley's
awarded stars and shove it down his
throat
um
let's just get right into the video
clips okay
this is
this is rudy this was broadcast on real
america's voice
it's all wacky
[Applause]
a general
jesus
the other day he said that the bagram
air force base is not strategically
important
i want to strategically grab his what he
had five stars 10 stars 12 stars he has
so many stars they're coming up into his
ears
i wanted to grab his stars shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles from
china [ __ ]
china is going to be our enemy for the
next 40 years
you have an air base 400 miles from them
and you're giving it up idiot
what
i like the one guy yelling right in the
audience hell is wrong with you
who paid you
christ
that is crazy
i don't know i shouldn't get into this
what biden did in the last two weeks is
freaking insane
it cannot be explained
[Applause]
yeah well
20 years ago
i did my job for the country
i'm very proud of it
but i did it because of them
what bernie
demonstrated to you i was so happy he
did
it this is it's it is sad more than
anything right you can't show everybody
right you can't show look
every one of them would like to show you
the 10 people that supported them
right espo
right joe right
you're gonna do it on your own how many
people did you have helping you
i had denny i had tony
howard i had joe
phil was in the mail room and a lot of
people
taught where's tony
i'm had these people that were with me
really really strange stuff and then
eventually he went into his queen
elizabeth impression
and it if you can imagine it got even
more weird
she said you did
you did a wonderful job
on september 11
and therefore i'm making you an honorary
knight commander
of the
royal something rather
i turned down a knighthood because if
you took a knighthood you had to lose
your citizenship
i know prince andrew is very
questionable now i never went out with
him
ever
never never had a drink with him
never was with a woman or a young girl
with him whoa what
making a lot of denials unprovoked
aren't you rudy
one time
i met him in my office and one time when
we had the party right bernie you were
there yeah okay anyway so rudy giuliani
really just an embarrassing fall from
grace
rudy giuliani recently said he doesn't
think he's ever done an interview drunk
doesn't think but he did say i drink
normally like scotch i drink scotch he
also said i'm not an alcoholic i'm a
functioning
i probably function more effectively
than 90 of the population and whether
that's a freudian slip where what he's
saying is he's a functioning alcoholic
or just that he functions really well
not really clear but just a very sad
state of affairs for rudy giuliani i
think it's time now with the 20th
anniversary to retire these 9 11 annual
dinners they've gotten just a little bit
too off the rails and if we end up
hearing anything about rudy and prince
andrew certainly that would be
interesting given his completely out of
the blue denial there okay i want to
talk about something that is
unfortunately going to become a trend
which is people finding ways
to get a
pseudo
reas real i guess i would call
uh exemption
for either
vaccination or mask wearing okay as we
see more and more requirements put in
place even if the requirements are what
we would call like a soft requirement
where it's like
you got to get vaccinated or you can
test weekly so you could just test
weekly as we are seeing more and more
schools including in the state of
florida say
no no no to ron desantis even if you
don't want masks in schools
we the school board are putting masks on
these kids because they're unvaccinated
and we need to do it it just makes sense
you're going to see more and more
shady mechanisms for people to try to
get themselves or their kids out of
wearing a mask or getting a vaccine
there is a chiropractor offering mask
medical exemption notes in
florida
business insider has a report a florida
chiropractor issued over 500 mask
exemptions for students in sarasota
county
um
a chiropractor in florida okay as i said
district spokesman craig miniglia told
the herald tribune a third of all
medical exemptions in the district
were signed by chiropractor dan bush at
twin palms chiropractic one guy one guy
the county started imposing mass
mandates on students on monday defying
florida governor ron desantis executive
order banning mass mandates that's last
monday this all happened over the last
week
after rumors started circulating that
bush was giving out pre-signed medical
exception forms sarasota county school
superintendent brennan asplin issued an
updated mask exemption form on tuesday
mask exemptions can now only be issued
by licensed medical doctors osteopathic
physicians or advanced registered nurse
practitioners bush had denied
accusations that he was giving out
pre-signed forms i myself will tell you
i have not given exemptions to any
parents i have not met with
that's different he also says i'm not an
anti-mass person or an anti-vaxxed
person but i'm pro-freedom pro-choice
sarasota is one of 10 school districts
in florida going ahead with mandates
mass mandates against the governor's
order two school districts have had
funding withheld but are still
continuing with the mandate of course
florida's seeing a spike in covet among
children
cases among children under 12 up 30 the
week ending august 26th cases among
those 12 to 19 up 26
so check this out
um
this is video
from uh an event in uh florida where
people are
lining up in order to get exceptions
from this guy people just all lined up
working hard to prevent their kids
from having to wear a mask this was an
event held by this guy
um
these are pictures of armed guards
at the event let me see if i can put
them now
you know
typically
uh you wouldn't need armed guards
with
um
what i guess are bulletproof vests or i
don't know if you call it a flak jacket
it's it's looking even a little small um
and and long guns
in camo i mean like typically you don't
need that when you're doing something
medical in this way
um people saying how could this possibly
be legal
and one of the things that keeps coming
up is this
promo this event took place yesterday
mask exemption
evaluation event so that's important
right you got it you got to call it an
evaluation event
sunday september 12 at noon
8 26 south moon road in venice this was
yesterday and it says parent guardian
and student required to attend so they
have to be there
medical records helpful
but not mandatory so you can just show
up and be like you know
my kid struggles to breathe with the
mask or whatever
and then um i guess the good the good
chiropractor
would say
ma'am or sir
your kid qualifies for this thing now i
wonder if customers have to sign sorry
sorry patience customers the i wonder if
the patients of this chiropractor have
to sign a disclaimer
so that
if the maskless relative or someone that
gets the virus from them dies
they can't then go and sue this
chiropractor is that something that they
have to sign and imagine what is going
on in your head where
never mind saying i think i'm gonna find
a mask opt out for my kid
i think i'm gonna go and stand in line
for maybe hours to get a mask opt out
for my kid like what is going on in
people's lives what is going on in
people's heads that that is something
that they would go and that they would
do this sort of reminds me you know in
in the early days of medical marijuana
and as a reminder i believe it should be
recreationally legal and regulated and
all this stuff
in the early days of medical marijuana
there were
sort of what you would call like pro pot
doctors
where
you could just go
and there have been some investigations
on this about how how sort of silly it
was you go in and you say
i need a medical marijuana card because
my back hurts
and this would be a doctor you had never
seen before and they would have you do a
couple movements and they would say and
tell me where it hurts and then they
would just kind of like generically say
yeah here's a prescription for your
marijuana and you you get a card and
then you go and it was like sort of
understood
you know you're paying a couple hundred
bucks for the console and it's basically
just like a a rubber stamp type thing
this seems like the same thing the
difference being
someone just going and getting medical
marijuana when maybe they should really
only be getting recreational hurts no
one
and it actually potentially keeps
someone out of the
out of dealings with law enforcement for
something that shouldn't be a law
enforcement issue altogether all these
parents going and opting out their kids
from masks
actually has a societal effect and can
actually lead to we see more kids than
than at any point in the pandemic in the
icu and in the hospital for covid but
also then they bring it home to other
people it's a mess and it has a huge
societal effect but the the the consult
strikes me as some of what was going on
early
um with the absurdity of of the medical
only marijuana which is a very different
things
it's different medically
and it's different societally as well
this is not boding particularly well for
us exiting the pandemic anytime soon we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 david p this is actually really
really funny
last week
during live calls someone called and
they had some kind of power tool going
in the background and i asked if they
were running a lathe
the eggman actually called and i think
the eggman works in some kind of a
machine shop he called and actually
played the sound of a lathe for me real
really great work eggman take a listen
to this
hey dave
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
could be a band saw i don't know
[Applause]
yeah it went on for like a full two
minutes if you can believe it
[Music]
and then like another minute later
[Music]
does he sign off let's see
no it just cuts off okay all right thank
you eggman very clever the comedic
stylings of the eggman please if you are
using a band saw or god forbid a leaf
blower how are leaf how are gas powered
leaf blowers even legal
you don't know how many episodes of this
show have been ruined
by leaf blowers anyway please don't call
in if that's what you're doing we have a
great bonus show for you today the fbi
has released the first 911 document
after an order from joe biden
what is in this document
much anticipated what is in it
also more and more democrats
are accepting or even touting the label
progressive
i don't think they're particularly
progressive but it still raises an
interesting question is it now
politically advantageous to label
yourself progressive if you're in the
democratic party and then number three
on today's bonus show
restaurants in many parts of the country
are closing down indoor dining rooms
again
are we heading for a winter in the parts
of the country that have winter
with no indoor dining once again
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show join me by signing up at
joinpackman.com you'll get instant
access to the bonus show you can also
get access via patreon if you prefer
go to
patreon.com david pakman show
what a tremendous bonus show we have for
you today
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video